والى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اذ
قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت
23 طائره مسيره هاجمت الاراضي الاوكرانيه
خلال الساعات الاربع والعشرين الماضيه
مازن اذا حرب المسيرات هذه
وفي النهايه الكل يريد ان يتصدى لها
والدمار ربما قليل مقارنه بما تحدثه
الاسلحه التقليديه خلفك نرى دمرا كبيرا
حدثنا
نعم في الواقع هذا هو حال الكلم حيث اقف
حاليا الليله وفي كامل هذه المناطق ما بين
سلوفيا وكراماتوست ضمن هذه المنطقه الدمار
يستمر ويمتد على مساحات واسعه عمليا ما
يمكن الحديث عنه بان هذه الحرب التي باتت
اشبه بحرب استنزاف تخوضها اوكرانيا وروسيه
وقد باتت اشبه بالمستنقع على الاقل هكذا
يتم وصفها لبعض الخبراء هي تحمل عده اوجه
حرب مسيرات من جهه من جهه ثانيه حرب وحبوب
كنا نشهدها بالامس في الجنوب بالاضافه الى
حرب على خط الجبهه الامامي هنا في المناطق
الشرقيه بالنسبه للساعات الماضيه
هجومات المتكرره عبر المسيرات طالت
مقاطعات واسعه على مستوى اوكرانيا امتد
هذا الامر من خرسون الى دينيبرو مرورا
بزافولوجيا وصولا بطبيعه الحال الى مقاطعه
خاركاب وايضا الى كياف القوات الاوكرانيه
عن اسقاطها لاكثر من عشرين مسيره وان
الهجمات التي تم تنفيذها استخدم فيها ليس
فقط المسيرات ولكن ايضا الصواريخ المجنحه
وراجمات الصواريخ التي اطلقت حممها على كل
الخط خط المواجهه الامامي وايضا القرى
الخلفيه التي تقع ضمن هذا الخط الذي يمتد
مئات الكيلومترات سواء من مرورا بلوجانس
هنا على مستوى الجبهه الشرقيه ما تقول
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه خلال من خلال
تصريحاتها لسيما صباح اليوم هي تشير الى
ان قوتها ما زالت تحاول التقدم عند محاور
محدده ضمن مقاطعه
بالاضافه الى
تحقيقها تقدما على مستوى جنوب باخموت
وايضا في زابولوجيا ولكن بطبيعه الحال كل
هذه المعطيات المتفاوته من الميدان سواء
من هذا الطرف او ذاك لا يمكن التاكيدها
نتيجه عدم امكانيه الوصول فعلا الى تلك
المناطق التي تشهد المواجهات لانها منا في
داخل الاحراج ضمن كيلومترات ومئه
كيلومترات اراضي الشاسعه التي تفصل الخط
الاخير عن خط المواجهه عمليا ما يمكن
الحديث عنه بالنسبه للقياده الاوكرانيه
هنالك تجديد حاليا على ضروره الحصول على
نوعين من السلاح على الطائرات
بالامس خلال لقاء مع سفراء غربيين تحدث عن
ان التدريبات على طائرات الاف سته عشر
ستنطلق هذا الشهر بالنسبه للطيارين
الاوكران وبالتالي هو يعول على هذا السلاح
وان كان سياخذ شكرا كي يدخل الى ساحه
المعركه بالاضافه الى مطالبه المتعلقه
بالصواريخ المتوسطه وبعيده المدى لضرب
مراكز التسليح والمراكز الاستراتيجيه
التابعه للقوات الروسيه